servus und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich habe ich habe ja
letztens schon mal ein riesengroßes
bounty gemacht heute machen wir passend
zum weihnachts thema
heute machen wir passend zum weihnachts
thema das größte plätzchen der welt
dafür gehen wir gleich die zutaten
einkaufen aber vorher leute möchten wir
unter anderem dieses t shirt hier und
den weißen holten noch kaufen könnt ihr
blau connect ist schon ausverkauft ist
nur noch drei tage online davon was
hamburg check ist auf jeden fall ab
erster link in der beschreibung führt
dazu ein normales blech braucht man fünf
gramm mehl 350 gramm butter sahne gramm
zucker und 4 eigelb das sind wie gesagt
die zutaten für ein ganzes volk wir
machen das jetzt so wir nehmen die
doppelten zutaten machen daraus ein
einziges plätzchen das heißt wir
brauchen ein kilogramm mehl 750 gramm
butter 4 gramm zucker in 8 falls alles
direkt neben division vorgelegt ja ja
drei tage später lehrte bis jetzt
mögliche und jetzt geht erst mal dieses
ausrüsten
[Musik]
scheiß auf diese weise all das ist es ja
der bäckermeister ak der maultaschen
boss und natürlich natürlich
sp-präsidenten wie gesagt nicht in der
beschreibung jetzt verwehrt wird
plötzlich gemacht
doch eine schüssel große schüssel unten
am kühlschrank da unten daneben
ok-präsident durch leid dass du diese
orden freistellt in diesem kreis um mich
herum schwimmen was leute ich will mich
fragte später das erste mail eintracht
und stoppe tag ein kilo mehl jetzt als
nächstes butter zucker und ei gerster
gebrauchen 750 gramm butter also exakt 3
packung also das ergibt teig für sechs
löcher oder sowas backofen auf 175 grad
ja mach du es mal kurz was jetzt
brauchen wir 400 gramm zucker auf den
film sogar abstellen leute dieses ganze
derben es halt so habe das jetzt auf dem
zweiten ironischen level die gäste ich
jetzt hier machen bis zu erklären gab
heute die am ernst gibt leute die am
chronisch gedeckt weil die idee zum sie
jetzt hier die dort ironisch stemmen
weil ihr die ohne sterben auch dumm sind
es vollkommen verdreckt was ich sagen
wollte ich weiß im bootshaus in köln und
da haben so viele leute galt es war so
schlimm
auf der tanzfläche die ganze zeit
allerdings apple xsan felder oder so die
leute mit rock märz das eiweiß da unten
rein ist junge eigelb hier braucht das
walter witzel im film wenn das jetzt
selbst weisen eine trennung jetzt an das
letzte
[Musik]
so etwas passiert oh mein gott an dessen
gesicht so dass kinder den sternen wie
fliegen wie möglich als 23
[Musik]
das sind unsere zutaten bisher und
darauf setzen teilt herstellen
[Musik]
was war das mal nicht weil das ding
ausmachen lassen die falsche richtung
gedreht jetzt vorwärts
es ist schon ein typischer letzten teil
weiter es ist aber nichts wissen
das ist unser teil dass unsere möbel
teig so leute das ist jetzt unser
welchen bis verfassten fußball 61
stunden später ein bisschen braun
geworden aber so harry ihr ja ja das
ganze zeit gehörte ist mega ice unfall
noch ziemlich war ich deswegen schon mal
raus in die kette ein dickes ist nun das
ultrabook ich bin gespannt ist wird
dadurch das aus drei tage später so dass
die ganze sache es abgekühlt und jetzt
haben wir hier unser plätze auf der
werde jetzt sag mal raus hier jetzt zum
schluss gern nutzen wissen
er steckt ihr euch vielleicht noch ein
bisschen aber auf jeden fall danke fürs
zuschauen bis zunächst mal ein moment ja